is I do think to to a large degree how
this spreads will somewhat depend on how
well we all do at respecting the
guidance around social distancing and
staying at home you know I I know a lot
of people think that that doesn't apply
to them or that they're not at risk but
you know the reality is is that you know
we're not just doing this for ourselves
we're doing this because there are other
people in our communities who are more
vulnerable and by staying at home we're
reducing the likelihood that we get
exposed and therefore can pass it along
to someone else and I mean I've read
some the first-hand accounts of kind of
people who have it who have the disease
or doctors and medical professionals
we're treating people it's it's it's it
does not sound like an ordinary flu I
think it sounds like significantly it
can be significantly more severe so I
just really encourage everyone to follow
the guidance from your local governments
on this I mean I know on this livestream
there are people from all over the world
so it's not just one government whose
guidance I'm suggesting that you follow
but around the world especially in the
US and in Western Europe and a lot of
other places the the guidance at this
point is please stay at home be careful
do it not only to kind of keep yourself
and your family safe
but do it to keep the whole community
safe and I think that that is that's
that's a really important thing here is
the quote that I've picked to kick us
off if you stay positive in a negative
situation you win let me say the quote
again today if you stay positive in a
negative situation you win what exactly
are you winning you're winning the war
against negativity you're winning the
war against despair you're winning the
war against stress and you know
negativity is a sneaky little bastard
let me tell you something
because it sort of creeps into your life
it creeps into your mind it creeps into
your skin and into your blood pressure
and before you even realize it
you started to succumb to it and how do
you know that you are succumbing to
negativity well first of all it depletes
you it has a heaviness to it it has an
intensity to it and when you succumb to
negativity it changes your character you
snap at your kids you snap at your
teammates you feel stuck you feel on
edge you feel tense and that's why I
want to talk to you about the power of
your attitude right now because your
brain is a pattern recognizing machine
and when you succumb to negativity
whether you think you're doing it or not
your brain will automatically start to
see more negativity and feel more
negativity which is why it's so easy to
get stuck ruminating and worrying and in
this sort of loop that you can't get out
of and so we're going to talk today
about building a positive attitude as a
habit now why do you want to build a
positive attitude as a habit right now
well first of all because a positive
powerful attitude is infectious it
inspires other people it makes you
resilient and from a mindset perspective
it will help you spot more positive
things what positive things could you
spot you can spot opportunities you can
spot solutions to the problems that
you're feeling you can spot problems
solving strategies you can spot ways to
connect you can spot ways to be more
innovative and so positive attitude
reads more positivity that's why I want
to teach you how to do it because it's a
strategy did you hear that word so a
powerful positive attitude is not only a
habit I want you to develop but it is a
strategy and you're deploying other
strategies right now to make you strong
and to make you safe you're washing your
hands you're getting supplies you're
editing your news intake you're
connecting with friends developing the
habit of a powerful attitude is a
strategy and when you practice having a
powerful attitude what happens as it
becomes a habit
what's a habit it's just a pattern that
you repeat so instead of succumbing to
negativity which can become its own
habit you're powerful attitude becomes a
habit and look I'm not talking about
like saccharine stupid unrealistic throw
caution to the wind let's just be
positive I'm positive I'm not going to
get this I'm positive I should go on
spring break because I'm not at risk I'm
positive that I don't have to worry
about that
that's not positivity that's stupidity
okay what I'm talking about is the kind
of powerful attitude where you are able
to see opportunity in any moment where
you are able to keep your wits about you
in any moment where you are able to have
an attitude about what you're facing
that keeps you strong and keeps you in
control that your attitude day to day is
keeping you anchored so even when the
headlines come in if you happen to see
them and they wig you out and you feel
yourself succumbing you can go right
back to bone having a powerful attitude
simple grounding tool you ready and it
builds off the five-second rule
what is the five-second rule you know
you count backwards five four three two
one to either cut off negative thoughts
or five four three two one
to push yourself to do things that
you're scared to do or don't feel like
doing we're going to start with five
four three two one as a grounding tool
five and I want you to do this with me
right now five things in this moment
that you can touch or see that bring you
joy I want you to write five things in
the comments do it right now I want you
to settle into your chair or settle into
the ground if you're standing and
watching me and I want you to look
around wherever
is that you are and I want you to type
five things that you can touch or see
right around you right now that bring
you joy you name five things you can
touch or see you give yourself for
compliments you then talk about three
people that you were going to reach out
to that you love
nothing nothing sparks innovation like
like a crisis and I think this is an
opportunity for an existential flex
which I've wrote a written about in the
infinite game where we you make dramatic
shift instead of doubling down on old
business models and panicking saying
okay how can we bring our cause to life
in this this is really a time for an
infinite mindset and it's really kind of
been amazing
watching some companies have a finite
month set and some committees that have
an infinite mindset perfect example of
finite mindset is the cruise industry
big cruise ships like why are there
still cruises going I don't know what's
going on I haven't talked anybody in the
cruise industry I hope I'm wrong but I
hope they didn't get together and say
we're gonna lose too much money let's
just keep it going until we're told to
shut down which was a finite mindset an
infinite mindset is any organization
that's trying to be ahead of the curve
that says in the long run we're gonna
hurt in the short term our people are
gonna come together when I solved this
problem but in the long run we're gonna
be better off for it and more important
we're gonna we're gonna do good for
others this is a time for us not just to
think about ourselves but to think about
the impact we have on others that's what
this coronavirus is all about you know
I've heard some people say more people
die from car accidents but we we haven't
stopped driving yeah but one car
accident doesn't exponentially create
more car accidents and so this is this
is really a test of our empathy it's our
test of our ability to think of
ourselves and our own safety we
absolutely have to do that but also to
think of the impact we have on others
are we practicing social distancing now
at the supermarket you know are two
people going after the same thing or is
one sort of stepping back
this is what it means to sort of think
about others what we have right now is
the beginning of a slog but what makes
something a slog is it lasts a long time
and we've been talking to my friend
Brian on his podcast the other day what
I said was when they write the history
of this decade of you your biography
what are they going to say you did this
week this month next month because
that's what we get to do is become the
person we want to become and if you are
lucky enough to be sheltered in place
and safe here's the question what are
you good at that you can become great at
in the next three or four weeks because
becoming great at something is an
opportunity it's a privilege and if all
you're going to do is survive the next
four weeks you've just wasted four weeks
you're never going to get back but if
you figure out how to dig in and get
great at something well then it's time
well spent
I've ready
[Music]
you have to be ready girl ready here we
go thank you everybody thank your
neighbors I hear them that's our only
way neighbor listen I can hear them
that's so you know that's so us
we can't see them but we can hear them
with you guys you hear that
you confess that okay if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there get
moving
accept reality